to see fox get off early
[Applause]
so good for them offensively mark was
the spacing on that last offensive
possession for the kings that young man
is hustling westbrook with a deep three
ball
blend with the rebound
and the sacramento kings with a
fiery and ferocious close but another
offensive rebound by the lakers man
you've got to finish your possession
with the defensive rebound that's the
guy you want shooting
and the lakers half a step faster again
they're killing the kings
howard with another offensive board
man four for a dollar in his hands that
time for the slam
and that's what happens when fox pushes
tempo great things happen if you run
with him if you run with tyrese you're
going to get a good look or they're
going to get a great basket just down to
three
monk in a rush
tipped up
with the rebound back out to james
the drink lebron the locomotive contact
and here's westbrook
that's before the step through oh metoo
told him to take it out of here
aaron fox doing damage in the paint
westbrook
works on barnes
los angeles with a two-for-one
scenario here russell will take
advantage of it but misses
westbrook left all along with good
reason
and
buddy healed
is going to be called for the foul
westbrook against barnes stock
at seven
behind the screen
westbrook still off